Gideon Intrater, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you.
Thanks. It's good to be here.
So, we're gonna talk
about metal today, right?
Bare metal.
Gideon, you know,
as a young entrepreneur,
going through Stanford here in Palo Alto,
we see all the sexy things on the news
and all these new and shiny devices
and really really cool things
but sometimes I think
we forget to look back
and really the core
of what's happening
and the core of technology,
which you've been dealing with
for quite some time now
in VP engineering positions
and CTO positions.
Let's talk about metal.
But first, Gidy, tell me a little bit
about where you come from.
Okay. So, I've been a CTO architect
pretty much my whole career.
I've started way way back in Israel
and was heading the
computer architecture team
at National Semiconductor.
Moved to the US with ... worked
for a good number of years
for another CPU company
called MIPS Technologies.
And until this morning,
I was working at the
semiconductor company called Adesto
which today was acquired
by a different semiconductor company called -
Mazel Tov.
Dialog Semiconductor.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, we're all happy about it.
You're saying it so casually.
Really, mazel tov.
Yeah. Thank you.
How many acquisitions
of this now have you been a part of?
Oh, a good number of acquisitions.
There's a lot of stuff that's happening
in the semiconductor business.
Now it's not as visible
as the software business
or the apps business,
but a lot of things are happening.
I was at MIPS and it was acquired.
I was consulting a number of startups
that were a bunch of them were acquired
and now this company that I'm in
was the deal was closed this morning.
Unbelievable.
Gideon, why is this not in the news?
I mean, this is obviously in the news.
You just have to look a little bit deeper
than another autonomous
vehicle company being acquired.
But why is bare metal
not in the headlines?
Well, first you just don't read
the correct sources of media, right
That's 100% true.
Well, it's not as sexy as software.
It takes us much longer to get
to an exit in this business.
This business requires
significantly higher investments.
So, two people in their garage
cannot really get a company to an exit
within a couple of years.
That doesn't happen.
Adesto, which is the company
that I was a part of
has been around for 13 years
before it was acquired
about eight, nine years
before it went public.
Wow.
So, it takes much much longer.
And the problem is we're building
semiconductor devices,
you call it bare metal,
but what we're doing is
designing semiconductor chips
that are pretty much the baseline
for pretty much all the software
that's being used in the world.
And we have to do a lot of things
to make this happen
and it just takes time and money.
Okay. So, let's dumb it down for me
because I know nothing about this.
What is the semiconductor business?
What are these technologies?
What are you building
on a day by day basis?
So, it depends.
Different companies are
building different things.
Everybody knows about Intel
which is building the CPUs
that are driving the PCs.
And now Apple is gonna be building
their own CPU that's gonna drive
the new Mac machines.
So, these are the things
that are typically much more in the news.
Then there's another tier of companies
that are building products
that go into cell phones.
So, a lot of people know about Qualcomm
and other such providers
But then you go deeper,
and for example the business
that we're a part of
which is the industrial IOT,
these devices are done
by a whole bunch of smaller companies.
And most of them
you just don't have a clue
that these devices are sitting
within your printer
or your food processor or -
We're literally talking
about the chips.
The chips that are in almost everything
that we see in our day to day right now.
Exactly.
And many of them include CPUs inside.
So, a lot of them at the end of the day,
are running software.
So, there's a lot of design
that goes into these systems.
First building the chip
then building the software around it.
So, even the software people
that are building the software
that goes into that.
I'm not in the news
nobody knows about them.
but that's what actually
is driving your car
and that's what driving pretty much
every one of these devices
that you're buying at Amazon.
Right. That's just incredible.
And take me back a few years
because you've been in this space
for quite some time.
And I grew up into a world that
IOT, Internet of Things devices,
are prevalent
and almost everything I touch
has a brain of its own.
But I think when you started
in this industry,
it wasn't like this, right?
No, no, no, no, no.
I've been in this business about 30 years.
And even at that time,
computers were relatively scarce.
There was typically a car had
one processor that was controlling
the engine and that was it.
Today, a car will have
tens and tens of microprocessors
that are doing everything
from rolling the windows down all the way
to showing you the way.
Even a cell phone has a number
of microprocessors inside
dealing with different functionality.
So, there's microprocessors
practically anywhere
and most of them are hidden.
Most of the people don't even know.
And this, what the Internet of things
is doing today
is what used to be called in the past,
embedded systems
which were systems where the software
was deep inside.
Nobody knew that about this software.
It was just done by whoever
built the system.
But there was no way
to update or upgrade it.
Now, with the Internet of Things,
pretty much all these pieces
are capable of being upgraded
and updated over time
which makes it beautiful.
It allows you to add features
later in time.
TESLA made a whole business
of upgrading your car pretty much
after you actually bought it
which is something that was unheard of
in the car industry before.
Incredible. So, what is there to come?
Because it seems that now
everything is already connected
and everything is pretty much
communicating with itself.
So, what are the big milestones
that we can foresee
in the next few decades?
The big thing that's happening right now
is actually taking AI
and driving it all
the way to the edge of the network.
So, the camera in your in your door
will actually be able to figure out
whether it's you or somebody else.
So, and a whole bunch
of other applications
where the knowledge to know
how the processing power,
whether extended processing power
or even AI will all be
at the end of the network,
the edge of the network,
without the need to go back to the servers
and make decisions and do that
requires first for you to be connected,
and second there's latency.
You don't want stuff
to go up to the network
and you don't really want Amazon
to actually take all the words
that are being said
within your living room
and send them up to their server.
You want to get the service,
but you want it to be done locally
without Amazon actually
getting that information
and storing it on their server.
So, a lot of this intelligence coming down
right to the edge of the network
will make a big change in the way
these devices are operating.
Right. So, and it sounds to me that
there are some hidden difficulties
or hidden challenges
that a software engineer like myself
may not even realize
because I could be developing
artificial intelligence models
pretty easily
either using AutoML by Google
or just TensorFlow with Python or PyTorch.
But it sounds like what you're saying
is that the challenges
of running these models on device,
on the camera that's on the door
is not just the software.
There's a lot of the processing power
and the memory,
those are all challenges
that we're still facing today.
Right. I can't afford to put
a server farm in my house.
So, you have to figure, we have to figure
out ways to make these algorithms
more efficient, to make
the hardware more efficient
so it would be able to run it.
In many cases,
you need to be running it
with a limited amount of energy.
For example, the battery operated devices.
So there's a lot of innovation
that's going on right now
into building devices
that are smarter and capable
of doing these smart things at the edge
with the limitations of cost, power
and pretty much everything else
that is what you expect
at the end of the day to have
in your right next to your front door.
Definitely.
So, the things that you're building,
are these the challenges
that you're working on,
making these things possible?
Yeah. We're working on AI at the edge.
We're also working
on security at the edge.
So, all these devices need to be secured
and you really wanna make sure
that nobody manages
to penetrate in your house,
into your bank account,
through your connected fan, right?
So, there's a lot of work
that's being done in these areas as well.
Yeah. I believe that
it was, somebody shared with me a paper
from the Technion
of a couple of people who managed
to actually hack a ceiling fan
and get some personal data
about people through that.
Right. Right. Right.
Pretty fascinating.
So, what excites you about this?
I mean, this does sound exciting now
that you're explaining what it allows.
But at the end, you're not working
on the camera of Ring
and you're not working on the ceiling fan.
You're working on the technologies
that then companies can use
to make their IOT, right?
Right. But what's happening
is that the engineering companies
that are building the end product
are becoming trying to become
leaner and leaner.
And what happens is that
the semiconductor vendors
that are offering devices
to these applications
are providing significantly more software
and more of the application
within the device, within their offering.
If you look today at TV, for example,
the chip that's actually controlling the TV
comes from a vendor that provides
not just the chip,
but the operating system
and a lot of the software.
At the end of the day, the various OEMs,
the main difference
between their devices would be
just the brand name on that
pops up when you turn on the TV.
Could easily be that 90% of the software
is the same software that was built
or provided by the semiconductor vendor.
So, semiconductor vendors
are actually becoming much more
of a vertically integrated suppliers
of a lot of the software
and a lot of the solution.
We're providing these devices.
We're providing the software.
We're providing even boards
that include all the pieces together.
And then in many cases,
OEMs in China and in Taiwan
would just take these designs and
pretty much take them to production.
Fascinating.
And are there demographic shifts
that you're seeing in the industry
in terms of young people coming into it?
Because I'm just thinking about
my experience at Stanford.
It's much sexier to go into software
and just use Python to write these
machine learning code.
And honestly, most of the companies
that are coming to hire on campus,
that's what they're looking for.
I don't remember a single company
that came that had stand out and said,
"Come work with us
in the semiconductor industry."
So, what's happening with that?
Well, our industry
is actually becoming older.
You go and visit the offices
and you'll see people that are
slightly older than the people
that you would see at typical Google site.
Right.
Yeah, that's true.
Although we're still getting
a lot of young engineers,
there is a shift of engineering
from the US into other places where people
value the semiconductor business more.
So, you'll see tons of startups in China.
Really?
You'll still see a bunch of startups
coming up in Israel.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, why was Israel a hub
or is still a hub for this?
Why is that?
That's a good story.
It has to do with multiple
different things,
but one of them was Intel.
Intel came to Israel in 1974
and started the design center.
And then within a few years,
engineers from Intel start moving
to other companies they thought
that'll have better opportunities
with still with American companies.
So, Motorola and National Semiconductor
started design centers.
But then in the late '80s,
people started realizing
that there's opportunities with startups
and money came in.
A lot of people got to a, pretty much
a glass ceiling in terms of
as a subsidiary of a big American company,
you couldn't get any further.
So, what happened was that,
and money was relatively abundant.
And so, startups started
and I can tell you that in the early 2000s,
Israel was probably more startups
than practically any place in the world,
maybe with the exception of Silicon Valley.
Even now, I think there are more
semiconductor startups in Israel
than practically anywhere in the world.
It's not the same numbers as they were
in the early 2000s,
but it's still a huge number.
So, it's not that it was more common
just to go to the Technion
and study the space.
It was more so that the industry by chance
came to Israel in 1974,
people saw the opportunity
and it got everybody excited?
Yeah. It was an exciting business.
Think about it, at that time
the other businesses were mostly
build boxes for ...
Yeah.
So people, some of the top people in the industry
or actually the top students
out of the Technion, went to work
for Intel, National, and Motorola.
At the time, I remember
I joined a little bit later than that,
much later than that
about 15 years later.
But at the time,
for every job at National,
we had about 100 people
that were applying.
Wow.
And we definitely rejected people
that were extremely good.
Some of them are CEOs of companies
that exited with millions
and millions of dollars.
And we told them,
"No, you're not a fit for working for us."
We could just pick whoever we wanted
to work at the company.
Unbelievable. And is there now,
is there a scarcity in good engineers
in the semiconductor space?
I think there's always been scarcity
in terms of good engineers.
Good engineers are not growing on trees
and it's always been a challenge
and now there's definitely
a bigger challenge due to the fact
that there's a lot of people
that are going to other businesses.
And I don't think that the universities
are generating enough engineers,
neither in the US nor in Israel.
Right. And it's interesting to hear
that there's, it seems that
there is a shift to Asia
for a lot of these businesses
as opportunities are rising.
And I'm really curious to know
about leadership
in the semiconductor space.
I talked to quite a few executives
and leadership positions
in the software space where I'm at.
What is it like leading technology and
leading teams in the semiconductor space
from your experience?
Is that different
than in the software space
or are these sort of two similar animals?
I think they're pretty similar animals.
There is obviously a little bit
of a difference in terms
of what you need to achieve -
Right. Also the length of time
that it takes to come to production.
Right? I mean, it takes years versus months.
There's also the risk.
Software doesn't have to be perfect
when it comes out of the factory.
You can update it and upgrade it,
and people invented this model of
let the customer
debug my code.
You can't do that with semiconductor.
With semiconductor, you take the chip out,
meaning you take it to production.
And then if you have a bug,
it will take you about six months
to fix that bug.
So, and the cost of fixing that bug
could be hundreds of thousands
or could be millions of dollars.
So, you can't really afford
to have bugs.
So, the result is that
the complexity of semiconductor devices
is not as big as a complexity
of a big software system where
there's hundreds of people working
on the same project.
I think the biggest projects are
Intel's microprocessors, probably
one or two thousand people
working on the program.
Most programs are much much smaller
with tens or hundreds of people.
But, so I think at the end of the day,
software systems could be
significantly more complex
and more difficult to manage,
however they manage it to just operate
not be bug free
where in the semiconductor business,
you have to figure out a way
to make it bug free.
And the result was a lot of tools
that were designed to help the engineers
actually figure out ways to clean the bugs.
Bugs are always in error,
and you just need to figure out a way
to get most or all of them out
of the design before you roll it out.
I mean it sounds pretty scary.
You've got to experience quite a few
roll-outs and deployments of these chips.
I mean, you deploy them and you're like,
"Okay. We did our thing.
I guess we're working on the next thing
And let's just hope that we don't wake up
and see an article that says
that there is a huge bug
in one of our chips."
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you've seen what happened to Intel
with some of these security bugs.
This is a disaster.
The number of chips that are deployed
and the time that it was found,
which was in some cases
years after the chips went to the market.
And now, what do you do about it?
So, in many cases
you find some work arounds.
Some of them are reducing
the performance of the device
and some of them
are not completely foolproof
and you have to live with it.
I think I recall that
there is an interesting case study
from one of my business school classes
of a time when a chip, it was found that
once every million calculations
it had a miscalculation error, right.
And it was a huge deal
of how does the company,
do they collect all the chips back?
But you can't because they're already
in all the computers.
And it was fascinating.
Right. Right. Right. Yeah.
It's a huge huge problem.
And there's tons of money
that's involved in that
both for the semiconductor vendor
that's building the chip
and for the OEM that sells it
at the end of the day.
Not an easy problem to deal with.
I think it takes a lot of courage to go
and sell something to millions of people
and hope that nobody finds anything wrong.
Hey, it's much easier than being
a structural engineer that's responsible
for a bridge that falls,
or a doctor that is
actually doing surgeries.
It's all relative.
On the spectrum it's not that bad.
I love it. Okay.
Gideon, right before we leave,
I wanna thank again for the time
that you're giving this.
And we didn't even talk about.
I'm very curious, I mean you're also part of J-Ventures
as a limited partner there.
So you're also active with
early stage startups
and you're active also
in helping do due diligence
and I love that you're balancing
these two worlds very technological,
yet also on the investment side.
But before we leave,
I have to ask three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. So, I would say
innovative problem solver.
That's probably
the easiest way to describe myself.
Innovative problem solver.
I love it.
It's all about solving problems
in the end, isn't it?
Yeah.
I love it.
Gideon, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
And congratulations on the
acquisition from today morning.
Yup.
Amazing. Amazing.
All right. Take care.
Bye bye.